[Music]
the United States the world's richest
country it is also one of the most
unequal 40 million people live in
poverty that's around 12 percent of the
population it has the highest poverty
rate in the rich world and three men own
as much wealth as the bottom half of the
population the good news is that poverty
has decreased over the past two years
but income inequality has increased
resulting in a growing gap between the
rich and the poor although the cost of
living varies from state to state the
poverty line is currently set at an
annual household income of twenty five
thousand one hundred dollars for a
family of four the wealthiest states are
coastal with the south having a higher
concentration of poorer States in
Mississippi around 20% of people live
below the poverty line
that's the highest percentage of any
state in the country in New Hampshire
it's less than half that California and
Missouri have run the same percentage
where as poverty in neighboring Virginia
and West Virginia is pulls apart poverty
rates can wildly vary between towns
within states take Paris Texas which has
a rate of 41 percent while in
neighboring Reno it's just 3 percent the
wealth divided can also be seen
fluctuating between blocks and even
streets in different blocks on separate
sides of Ocean Parkway in Brooklyn New
York the poverty rate is six times that
of the other poverty in America is not
only geographical it's also racial
african-americans are more than twice as
likely to live in poverty than white
Americans but it's Native Americans who
have the highest poverty rate of any
race in the country
and this is even higher for those who
live on reservations poverty declined in
the majority of states in 2017 income
growth welfare programs or more jobs
have led to the decline but if the
income of the top 1% continued to grow
faster than those of the other 99% the
gap between the rich and the poor will
continue to widen